wait have you have you used that filter
no it's so crazy wait what's the
craziest thing I'm not gonna say who and
I'm I'm sending love but I know somebody
who uses this filter and they post
pictures with this but they're doing it
on ironic no way can we can you guys see
this this is Cody with the filter I look
[__] hot I know it's it makes I wish
I actually look like I know I know and
sometimes I'll post a video with this
filter on and people will like send me
heart eyes and I'm like do you think
this guy exists you're I don't you can't
tell me you think I look hot like this
that's not what I look like it's
actually really offensive I'm like okay
I guess go hook up with him or if if you
can find him